bonsoir messieurs bonsoir arnaudo thézac
vous êtes géopolitologue bonsoir à vous
également us bell fait la consultant en
relations internationales et spécialiste
du monde arabe alors la situation en
afghanistan se détériore de jour en jour
cinq capitales provinciales sont
désormais contrôlées par les talibans
tout ça en l'espace de trois jours
comment se fait-il que les talibans
progressent aussi vite depuis quelques
jours maintenant l'armée afghane n'a pas
suffisamment de moyens d'effectifs pour
leur faire face
arnaud de thézac effectivement ça a
l'air d'être une una mystère puisque on
a trois cent mille soldats de l'armée
régulière normalement face à 75000
talibans donc effectivement on pourrait
imaginer que rapport de forces est pas
favorable aux talibans la question c'est
que les 2000 milliards de dollars que
les américains ont dépensé sur place ont
sans doute servi à autre chose qu'à
former une armée et que l'art me et pas
forcément par dont ils ont servi à quoi
ces deux mille milliards
écoutez iliad il ya plein de rapports
qui circule partout mais ils ont servi
et bien sûr à payer l'armée à faire des
camps mais surtout à payer les soldats
américains et payer le gouvernement le
faire ici ou là des travaux
d'infrastructures mais qui n'ont pas
abouti enfin c'est un grand gaspillage
je ne pensais pas très bien où l'argent
est placé
mais pour revenir à la situation
actuelle il n'est pas du tout évident
que les que le gouvernement puisse
fonctionner très longtemps et il suffit
de regarder les travaux diplomatique
récents qui sont en cours avec des
déplacements permanents des responsables
talibans
en chine le 28 juillet en russie en iran
qui même au turkménistan lundi également
sans le montrer était présente à chacune
des étapes des voyages diplomatiques des
chefs talibans et donc c'est un secret
de polichinelle que l'inde a également
négocié avec eux donc la négociation
d'après d'après la chute de kaboré des
gens courent
et les bombardements de l'histoire de de
quelques b-52's parquet du qatar ne
changeront pas grand chose younes
benfeld expliquez nous comment ce
fait-il que trois cent mille soldats
afghans n'arrive pas à faire face à
75000 talibans je crois que l'armement
des talibans c'est pas d'armement
qualitatif par rapport à l'armement de
l'armée afghan officiel mais ce qui fait
la différence c'est clairement d'abord
l'engagement des talibans pour avoir le
pouvoir et c'est aussi l'expérience
cumulée parce ce groupe pendant les
vingt dernières
les vingt dernières années il faut
rappeler quand même le contexte parce
que les américains nous avaient toujours
des relations avec les talibans d'abord
ils ont forcé les ans formé contre
l'union soviétique on l'est rappelant à
l'époque les combattants de la liberté
il y avait même cette alliance est
claire et nette entre les taliban et
l'organisation d'al qaïda et après y
avait la décision américaine de mettre
une guerre contre les talibans ont bien
sûr en compagnie avec avec le temps et
une guerre qui n'a pas abouti a réalisé
en fin de compte les réseaux les bons
résultats pour le pays c'est à dire la
construction des institutions l'armée la
police les institutions démocratiques le
fait de mettre en place une constitution
et là les derniers mois on a vu qu'il ya
un retrait américain
mal gérée qui laisse en quelque sorte
des traces sur le sueur sur le pays les
accords par exemple du doha n'ont pas
clairement défini les rôles des
différentes parties politiques et ce qui
se passe actuellement c'est une volonté
est claire des talibans pour avoir le
pouvoir
la maintenance est une très bonne
réponse pour ceux qui ont déjà défendu
le fait du de faire une solution
politique avec des groupes islamistes
terroristes parce que c'est ça le
résultat de chercher des solutions
politiques
impossible dans ce genre de contexte
maintenant l'afghanistan c'est aussi à
le carrefour géopolitique là où les
interventions et les ingérences
étrangères sont de plus en plus
intéressante d'abord avec le voisinage
parce qu il n ya le pakistan deux forces
nucléaires dans la région
mais je peux même aussi faire signer
référence par rapport à ce qui est écrit
cette semaine par la revue newsweek sur
cette alliance entre la russie et la
chine et l'iran qui on est clairement
une vision kovy par rapport à ce qui se
passe en afghanistan
s'ajoutant à cela bien évidemment le
sous-traitant on va dire américain qui
gère la turquie qui veut mettre la main
sur l'aéroport du du kaboul donc la
situation et l'est étaient très
compliquées entre les différentes
parties avec une intervention étrangère
alors les talibans semble incontrôlable
en ce moment sont partis pour multiplier
les conquêtes et ce qu'il bénéficie d'un
certain soutien extérieur c'est talibans
qu'il est qui les soutient qui les
financent bien sûr bien sûr si je peux
me permettre de répondre bien sûr qu'il
ya un soutien extérieur
si vous regardez la carte qui est
derrière moi oui ce pays et
l'afghanistan puis si vous avez pakistan
et puis là vous avez l'iran et là vous
avez la chine d'accord qu'une frontière
commune donc la chine elle est
intéressée par les matières premières
mais elle est aussi intéressé ce qu'elle
peut pas faire du temps des américains
par le passage direct depuis l'iran
jusqu'à jusqu'à jusqu'à la chine de
paille klein qui éviterait des
déconvenues de ses navires
éventuellement en cas de problème de
guerre maritime l'afghanistan ces 37
millions d'habitants à peu près la même
surface que le pakistan qu'un à 240
millions voyez ce que j'ai à 400% moi
donc c'est beaucoup plus facile à
contrôler pour une puissance comme la
chine
ça c'est numéro un deuxièmement l'iran à
gros problème avec le pakistan qui était
sous contrôle américain jusqu'à
maintenant c'est que les barrages ici et
c'est de l'eau n'est pas pour les
ruptures iranienne et l'iran n'est pas
du tout content que l'iran allait plutôt
content que on lui coupe le robinet donc
il ya une partie des talibans qui sont
également aidés par par l'iran parce que
l'état est bon c'est pas homogène
les chefs quelquefois de détente mais
sont pas forcément suivies par par tout
le monde
question d'ethnie qu'était enfin c'est à
la fois compliqué ça ensuite vous avez
des ressources outils gazière ou
pétrolière qui n'ont pas été encore
exploité mais qui le seront certainement
et puis vous avez l'opium ont nié que la
bénisse temps produit 90% de l'opium
mondial et que quand le mollah omar en
2000 était encore au pouvoir il y avait
pas un gramme d'opium qui était qui
était sortie de l'afghanistan tout avait
été détruit parce que c'était considéré
comme contraire à la norme islamiques
dès que les américains sont venus ça
recommence et on en est à deux cent
quarante mille hectares de champs de
pavot et on est à sept mille tonnes
d'opium ou à peu près entre 1500 et 5000
tonnes d'opium par an hors d'afghanistan
et le un des premiers relais est opium
dit on je veux pas me faire des ennemis
mais c'est ce que les rapports de l'onu
raconte on va passer par la turquie qui
veut reprendre les robes le contrôle de
la déjà en partie d'ailleurs mais il va
avoir le contrôle complet l'aéroport de
kaboul pour exporter quoi alors bon
visiblement
visiblement oui l'afghanistan très
convoité donc par de nombreuses nations
étrangères alors l'intervention
américaine en afghanistan elle a débuté
il ya 20 ans elle a été très critiquée
est-ce que younes belle falla les
citoyens afghans ne vont-ils pas
regretter le départ des américains qui
le rassure et tout de même une certaine
stabilité politique je crois pas qu'il y
avait une stabilité politique avec ce
qui s'était passé pendant les dernières
années avec de l'argent certes oui des
attentats strictement il ya aussi à vous
aussi la corruption qui a toujours
continué pendant les vingt dernières
années en plus il ya aussi il faut pas
oublier quand même que l'organisation
d'al qaïda il est toujours présente dans
certaines zones d'afghanistan avec aussi
les pays du voisinage c'est à dire sur
tout le pakistan
donc ce qui fait que la situation il est
il est très très compliqué les états
unis ne l'ont pas trouvé en fin de
compte une solution
institutionnel qui renforce le pays mais
ont continué à détruire ce pays par la
fois par le social de certaines
organisations indirectement comme les
comme les taliban ou même aussi elle le
fait d' affaiblir les institutions à
caractère on va dire libéral eux mêmes
ou même nationale maintenant je peux
comprendre par exemple les certaines
interventions ou une influence e russe
dans cette région parce que
historiquement l'union soviétique avait
toujours des intérêts dans l'afghanistan
le pakistan le tadjikistan qui ont formé
en quelque sorte les pays de l'union
soviétique mais là maintenant on efface
aussi avec un nouveaux acteurs dans
cette région qui est la chine
un acteur qui s'intéressent à l'asie
centrale
avec des enjeux géostratégiques mais
également aussi des enjeux militaires
c'est à dire que les objectifs
maintenant de certains grands 2e
puissance dont le monde c'est aussi la
création de bases militaires l'intérêt à
des ports maritimes adea des adm report
est donc cette guerre on va dire
contrôle l'est et l'ouest trouve à
certains moments des carrefours où des
pays comme comme l'afghanistan
maintenant il faut faire attention pas
seulement à la question de terrorisme il
faut faire attention aussi à la crise de
réfugiés que peut engendrer une guerre
en afghanistan dans une région poudrière
proche de notre pays qui manque aussi de
stabilité en l'occurrence le pakistan
armé de thézac à la communauté
internationale a condamné les attaques
des talibans comment est-ce qu'elle doit
réagir cette communauté internationale
fasse et bien à cette progression des
talibans sur le territoire afghan à ce
qu'elles ne devraient pas peut-être agir
plus efficacement sur le terrain on
voyait des troupes quelle est la
solution la plus adéquate
je pense que on est en train d'assister
à une recomposition totale de des
rapports de force dans le monde
les américains sont partis à la cloche
de bois en pleine nuit du jour au
lendemain mais il signale échec
stratégique majeure une défaite
militaire
qui est de surcroît et l'onu n'a plus
rien à dire il n'est pas crédible au
mois de juin et 6 ans à genève
on a eu une conférence entre l'admirent
poutine et joe biden ils sont venus
quand même avec leurs états majors
militaires et et d'aucuns ont des bonnes
raisons de penser qu' il ya eu des
décisions stratégiques qui ont été qui
ont été prises à ce moment là malgré le
fait que personne n'ait rien dit et donc
on est dans une géopolitique aujourd'hui
du secret on n'est plus dans un débat
public
les choses se font derrière les peuples
et on agite si vous voulez des choses
pour occuper l'esprit des peuples comme
les réfugiés mais derrière on va
négocier des milliards pour payer les
transferts on dit qu'on fait des grandes
réunions diplomatiquement fait les
songes
on ne dit pas ce qui si ce qui s'y dit
et ce qui se décide et on voit
qu'aujourd'hui c'est le rapport de
forces militaires locales et c'est bien
normal que la chine défendre son pré
carré
le problème c'est que des intérêts qui
sont contradictoires en particulier avec
l'inde que la turquie récemment cessé
s'est prononcé pour une restitution du
cachemire au pakistan on oublie que le
pakistan est un pays artificiel et que
les habitants du pakistan viennent du
gujarat viennent de dudu du tamil nadu
et viennent de partout en inde et que
les vrais occupants d'origine de ce pays
là bas c'est justement les pachtouns
c'est à dire les élèves parents et que
on oublie encore que à l'époque de thé
colonie anglaise est bien assez
d'hectares pour nous empêchant l'accès à
la mer l'afghanistan pour empêcher que
la russie s max et la mer et je pense
que ça c'est un des enjeux majeurs et
sans doute la plus court terme on
imagine et une réouverture du corridor
vers la mer pour la russie
younes belle fait là pour conclure vous
nous dites que ont mené par que les
talibans sont bien partis pour contrôler
l'ensemble de l'afghanistan quoi peut
ressembler ce pays où cos commandement
commandement taliban
on efface aussi à une nouvelle création
de l'état islamique sur ce que ce soit
si ça sera pas en syrie ou en irak mais
ça sera en afghanistan mais j'aimerais
bien on souligné
le fait que les institutions
internationales comme comme le lieu où
même où même le temps avance clairement
un fiasco total par rapport à ce genre
de crise ce genre d'institution créer ou
20e siècle avec avec des enjeux
clairement différente par rapport à ce
qui se passe actuellement le temps c'est
un complice on va dire de tout ce qui
s'était passé en afghanistan parce qu'il
a quand participer et contribuer à cette
guerre avec avec avec les américains et
présenter un soutien militaire à jure
politique sécuritaire mais en fin de
compte on arrive à qui a un
désengagement total et son prendre en
considération bien évidemment les drames
humains d'un peuple qui souffre depuis
plus de 20 ans soit à et qui n'a pas le
choix soit entre la la tyrannie on va
dire de l'islamisme terroristes ou bien
la tyrannie d'âne ou d'une nouvelle
forme de colonisation amérique younès
belle fait la merci et d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
consultant en relations internationales
et spécialiste du monde arabe
merci à vous également arnaud de thézac
vous êtes tous géopolitologue